olivier delorme hauteur de la grèce et
les balkans il est annie siros en grèce
s'élevaient d'ailleurs olivier delorme
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors les étudiants on le disait
vent debout contre le projet de loi
visant notamment instauré des
patrouilles de police dans les
universités est pourquoi cette volonté
du gouvernement elle gêne autant les
étudiants
écoutez il faut dire peut-être d'abord
elle jeunes des étudiants c'est pas
l'ensemble des étudiants qui sont dans
la rue aujourd'hui
et il y a une vraie et longue tradition
en grèce de d'anarchisme avec des
groupes qui sont organisés et qu'ils ont
joué d'ailleurs à certains moments un
rôle historique puisque ces groupes
anarchistes et notamment une université
à athènes l'école polytechnique a donné
la donné le signal en 1973-74 de la
révolte contre le régime dictatorial
donc il ya une tradition il ya une
tradition politique très très ancré dans
ce pays de contestation universitaire du
pouvoir et notamment quand ce pouvoir
est de droite
après il y à un état des universités qui
est assez dramatique c'est à dire et là
le gouvernement ne répond pas à la
question
c'est à dire que la politique de l'union
européenne depuis dix ans a mis les
universités grecques à genoux
on a supprimé un tiers des filières on
en a privatisé un tiers et donc il ne
reste un appareil universitaire que
traître est en crise
alors c'est les deux choses qui se
conjuguent dans cette affaire
c'est-à-dire une crise de long terme de
l'institution universitaire grecque et
une tradition de contestation de dégoût
des gouvernements en général dans cette
université
effectivement c'est sur un café
effectivement le l'opposition elle parle
elle d'une dune de dérive sécuritaire
cette dérive sécuritaire du gouvernement
est ce qu'elle est partagé par une
partie de la population à ce que la
population soutient ces étudiants qui
sortent dans la rue
écoutez c'est très difficile à dire dans
l'état actuel et avec la pandémie
on a beaucoup de mal à savoir ce que
pense la population
ce qui est sûr si vous voulez c'est qu'
un certain nombre de ces universités et
notamment quatre parce que cette loi est
elle cible emprunt elles ciblent surtout
quatre universités de hatten
polytechnique et l'université d'économie
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure où le
recteur a été agressé il ya très peu de
temps par un de ces groupes dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure
celle de thessalonique et celle de
patras les les autres universités ne ne
connaissent pas vraiment cette situation
c'est vrai que quand vous allez dans ses
universités
quand vous les approchez vous voyez tout
de suite combien les locaux ont été
comment je vais vous dire taille est
occupée prise en main par ces groupes
est donc un gouvernement de droite qui
s'est fait élire sur un programme de
droite en disant qu'il allait reprendre
aux mains les choses qu'on avait laissé
filer c'est effectivement une aspiration
d'une partie de la population
alors si vous laissez locaux sont très
dégradées et une partie du discours
d'une partie du discours du du
gouvernement est de dire si on ne met
pas de l'ordre là dedans c'est le
contribuable qui devra payer et payer
encore
réfection de ses locaux alors ce pays il
est très profondément divisée en deux
c'est à dire que vous avez vous avez une
partie de la population sans aucun doute
qui soutient les étudiants aujourd'hui
et vous avez une mesure qui est
inquiétante parce qu'elle remet en cause
la liberté universitaire mais d'autre
part vous avez une partie du pays et qui
a qui est qui qui n'acceptent plus
l'état en quelque sorte d'extra
territorialité de ces universités où ces
groupes font la loi
donc est-ce que l' équilibre de que
propose le gouvernement est justifiée
moi je peux pas vous le dire c'est très
difficile à dire mais on a une situation
de crise universitaire en grèce qui
s'enracine maintenant dans une dans une
dans un temps long et aucun des
gouvernements n'est arrivé à à remettre
de l'ordre dans ses universités avec des
avec des heures qui sont parfois très
violent il ya il ya un étudiant qui est
mort dans une dans une manifestation
l'autre chose qui met le feu aux poudres
c'est que le gouvernement veut mettre
fin à ce qu'ils appellent les étudiants
éternelle c'est à dire des gentils qui
ont le statut d'étudiant mais qui en
réalité ne font plus des études et qui
en réalité sont là une pierre de
l'agitation politique
voilà donc donc si vous voulez c'est une
situation très complexe très dangereuse
pour le gouvernement parce que la
contestation étudiante c'est toujours un
grand danger
justement on parle d'un dard confinement
total également en grèce à cause de
l'épidémie est ce que malgré ces
restrictions et bien la grèce s'attend à
de fortes mobilisations étudiantes est
ce qu'il y à des risques de violences à
ce que c'est une crainte aujourd'hui
pour le gouvernement il ya clairement
des risques de violences parce que ces
groupes sont très organisés et ils ont
ils ont une ils ont une tradition de
commandes organisation face aux forces
de police et de ceux ci voulaient se
sont pas des manifestations enfin il ya
une manifestation de masse mais derrière
il ya des groupes très très très
organisée donc il ya clairement pour le
pour le pour le gouvernement un très
grand danger parce que si jamais ces
affrontements aboutissent à un mort dans
la jeunesse là on aura une situation qui
sera très très difficile à gérer
comme elle l'a été pour le gouvernement
caramanlis dans les années 90 où un
jeune est mort et où l'opinion a basculé
à basculer massivement
il faut comprendre que la grèce est un
pays où la natalité est très faible ou
cinq cent mille jeunes sont partis du
fait des politiques européennes dans les
dernières années et où les les jeunes
bénéficient dans l'opinion en quelque
sorte d'un d'une grande
d'une grande tolérance et
d'agrandissement positif
donc si vous voulez il y a il ya un
danger pour le gouvernement à s'engager
dans une épreuve de force avec la
jeunesse
maintenant ce qui est très difficile à
évaluer dans les conditions actuelles
et c'est la proportion des étudiants qui
sont prêts à aller à une épreuve de
force dans les circonstances actuelles
et la capacité de ces groupes a mobilisé
et la capacité de la gauche
en réalité a mobilisé une grande partie
de sa jeunesse bien vraiment très
difficile à évaluer aujourd'hui
eh bien on suivra ça de près a en tout
cas sur rt france merci à vous olivier
delorme d'avoir répondu à nos questions
depuis ni siros en grèce je le rappelle
vous êtes auteur de la grèce et des
balkans